[Musique]
et en cette veille de vacances scolaires
vous devez vous en douter le rendez-vous
des juniors va vous donner des idées
pour profiter de ces deux semaines de
repos mais l'union par où cette semaine
mais je vous propose qu'on parte à
rambouillet parce que les équipes vont
tester est la créativité des plus jeunes
d'entre nous plusieurs ateliers sont
proposés en deux lieux la lanterne de
pôle culturel de la ville et le palais
du roi de rome le lieu classé monument
historique et ses rendez-vous tourne
autour d'une exposition même de deux
expositions c'est dans deux lieux celle
de béatrice quat'sous casa dessous
parlons une artiste française qui est
une formation de sculptrice alors avant
tout travailler sur le du volume
notamment avec des architectes la
trahison christian de portzamparc et
aujourd'hui elle fait de la peinture
elle fait des installations textile en
relation ou pas avec des oeuvres
anciennes et puis lt aussi des arts
graphiques voilà une oeuvre qui est
assez varié qui tourne qu'il y assez
récurrente qui peu tourné souvent autour
du thème du point voilà donc elle
travaille dans une relation au temps et
donc les activités sont adaptées à l'âge
des enfants
ça va de 30 minutes pour les plus jeunes
c'est à dire les 3 4 ans les ateliers
durent environ deux heures pour les 8 14
ans et les activités se déroulent là
aussi dans les deux lieux le palais du
roi de rome et la lanterne alors chaque
lui à son thème au palais du roi de rome
ce sont des peintures à dominante de
couleurs chaudes c'est ce qu'on a vu sur
les images à la lanterne c'est plutôt à
des toiles abstraites automne at-il
tonalités bleu et elles gagnent nous
explique cette fois comment se passent
ces ateliers il découvre l'exposition en
compagnie d'un guide conférencier et
ensuite sur l'eau la rage ils vont avoir
une petite pratique artistique donc les
tout petits vont simplement prendre un
petit fragment de tissu et faire comme
béatrice choisir une oeuvre et poser
leurs fragments de tissus en relation
avec la ils vont s'exercer à faire des
tout petits points sur un petit un petit
bristol et pour les plus grands ça va
bien sûr être un petit peu plus élaboré
vous utiliser des techniques qui sont
celles de l'artiste alors ça va être
deux
impressions du papier bulle ou encore de
la gouache l'idée c'est aussi de
manipuler plusieurs matières différentes
comme on peut le voir sur les images
alors les ateliers sont prévues les
mardis et mercredis des vacances de
février et les équipes vous conseille
bien sûr de réserver merci mélanie pour
ses idées donc de quoi vous occuper pour
toutes les vacances au moins jusqu'au 28
février